at what point should a writer have
earned the audience's trust
and if it's not there by that point it's
going to be hard to get it later
page one um
you know um i mean i'll look at a
screenplay
and literally line one
i'm already going really does this
person have the job i can't
look i can't look at one line and
definitively say but i but i'll tell you
what
you give me you show me the first
sentence or maybe not it can't be just
the slug line the slug line in one
sentence
of um you know you should it is
interesting but if i saw the slug line
in one sentence of
10 screenplays i bet you
i could tell you how much i'm going to
like that screenplay
um within probably 80 likelihood like i
can see a professional
crafted line in just two sentences um
i don't do that that harshly whatever
but like you know at least give them a
page or two
if i'm going to sort of evaluate
something but like um
there's just so many choices and you're
talking it's it's sort of like poetry in
a sense where
every word counts and you can often when
you've done it for so long
realize i don't need that word i don't
need that word i could subtract to
subtract you get that white space
flowing on the page
so you can um just very efficiently
and then muscular word choices and
specific words
there's so much to be seen again so i'll
even say this
if you take a if you take even the way
the slug line is formatted and the way
they're
talking about the time of day and those
things those are choices
and um and amateurs tend to make one
pool of choices and professionals tend
to make other ones
getting tendencies but like yeah i would
think 80
of the time i could look at two lines
and i could feel like
this is probably a professional or
somebody at least writing at the
professional level
and so if that page one is not
is not up to par it's going to be very
difficult almost impossible maybe to
gain that trust
for the reader or audience later on so
yes but it's not binary
right so what will happen is um you know
all
anybody who's spending the hours and
hours of time writing a screenplay has
some sort of
talent you know i mean they have
something going on right so
you know i don't think i've ever read a
screenplay that had like zero like
nothing right there's something you know
so um
but what will happen is i'll get to page
one if i was just picking up a random
script from random amateur writer
and i look at page one again
i look at line two or three and i'm
already knowing yeah this person's
probably
you know from the scale of totally
professional to total beginner
within two sentences i know that okay
this is probably where this person is
and i'll get to the end of the first
page and i'm now i have a 90
chance or 95 chance of knowing where
they are
now that being said if i'm a production
company and i'm looking for a thriller
and
my friend said he read he read this
thriller and it was amazing
and i read page one and i'm going okay
my friends i trust my friend he's saying
it's amazing i'm looking at this thing
it's not
a really a professional level written
thing it's kind of amateurish
i might not toss in the trash at that
point i might go um okay
but you're it's it's you're leaning
against it you're sort of you're you're
minimizing it so
it's important not to see it in a binary
way where it's this or that but at
certain point in hollywood it will be
binded
they'll give you first of all they're
not going to read the script unless in
one sentence
you can pitch the story um and then
they'll go oh yeah that's worth my time
and they'll give it a couple pages and
then
toss it when it's not any good it's more
than just formatting issues though you
said it's also like word choices
and you know it's not just how much
white's on the page or
even it's all those things right because
it's the screenplay format is so
um it's kind of clunky
it's a clunky format right um you know
uh
the way the slug line works and it just
it's sort of
yeah i mean whereas prose it's just like
a waterfall of words you know
i don't even write prose but like um but
the screenplay format is just
it's blocky um and so because there's
those limitations
um when you get really familiar with the
format you can see
people very quickly making choices
within this sort of format that are
you know different good or different bad
or different and experienced
you know there was a script a spectre
that came out a couple years ago that
was doing all sorts of crazy things with
fonts and craziness and um
i love a little of that when it's
organic and it feels inspired
but this script i i you know i wanted to
ring somebody's neck after about 30
pages
i was like you know oh wow cool idea and
i like it because they were really
stretching the bounds of the format
and then it felt like to me it was a it
was
at least to me for my sensibility was it
felt like a trick or a gimmick
it wasn't that they um to my mind
i wasn't able to find my way in
emotionally
to what their vision was you know so um
so
uh but i don't know i mean um but they
you know certainly made a splash
doing that and um and who knows maybe
other people really liked it then that's
that's great that's the thing is it's a
subjective business so um
you know i have very refined and and
strongly held beliefs but i'm just one
opinion you know i mean we
you know we might disagree about what
won the oscar in any given year you love
it i hate it or vice versa
and that's a movie that's produced and
heralded as the best
that we've got and stark disagreements
so um certainly any spec script by any
writer
you know it just needs to be i mean if
i'm working with somebody i'm
what's interesting about that is if i'm
working with somebody my opinion
doesn't even really come up because it
doesn't matter my what i do is
or even when i write my own stuff it's
i'm an advocate for their audience
and i gently and inspired way just
ask questions what i think that their
audience is going to be wondering
you know why you know i think your
audience is going to
want a more cohesive idea here you know
what if
like you're all i know your audience is
craves to have a sense of irony in your
concept
you know i know your audience might you
know when you're thinking about
constructing your log line
they want a character's goal that is
just driven it's powerful and there's
these stakes and then there's a conflict
so i just sort of i articulate
what i'm in my experience i believe
their audience is going to be thinking
and that gives the people i work with um
a really
fine sort of goal post for them to
shoot at and that's the great thing is
that um whenever you whatever your
writing process is or whatever your
support system
is you you want to have a really high
quality feedback loop so you can stay
focused on the task at hand
in an inspired way and move as quickly
as possible
what slows up writers is they don't have
a quality feedback loop system
they kind of figure out their own they
might read a book but they can read a
book and they don't know if they're
actually applying the book or not
um and then they might have all sorts of
hang-ups about getting feedback
because this person yelled at them they
take toxic or they or their
you know they take too much feedback and
they drown her out their own voices all
sorts of nightmares but like
having a world-class um feedback and
development system is absolutely
one of the best things i've done for my
career i mean and i'm
so good at it i can even i can even take
somebody that's like a layperson that
doesn't even know the business
and i can ask them
for feedback in a certain way and it
gives me a high quality echo of what's
going on
if you just hand them if i hand my
sister the script and my sister is
awesome
and uh she used to always watch our high
school movies and she always has
belting laugh so we called her like the
laugh anchor but anyway
but in general if i was to give her my
script and she would basically say oh
i liked it or i didn't like it right
that's sort of base level
analysis um
but what you can do is take even a lay
person if you
direct them in the right way with how
you ask for feedback
so you know uh you know for my sister i
could say
was there any um what was your favorite
character
was um which character do you feel like
you wanted to know more about or needed
more sort of development
which scenes felt like you didn't need
them right these are
questions she absolutely can answer um
definitively from her opinion and she
would have
almost never thought to tell that to me
if i just gave it to her because she's a
lay person right she's just going oh
i like this line of dialogue or this was
great or i didn't like it or whatever
so um so whatever
writers use for their feedback system
whether i have a writer's group
or a coach or accountability partner or
whatever
works for them i would invite
them to have it be a really high quality
echo
because we're anticipating we're in the
reaction business we're anticipating
that reaction from the audience
and the better that feedback loop can be
and the quicker it can be
the faster our career will move forward
what do you say to screenwriters who
are insulted or feel that it's too rush
or you're not respecting the craft
when you can tell by page one or even
really
halfway down the page whether it's a
professional level screenplay
what do you say to those people um it's
a great question and
i know a lot of writers feel very
strongly about that like how could you
even tell my screenplay is any good if
you've only read
you know you know one page or even a
couple lines that's really ridiculous
um okay no
fine you can disagree with me all you
want um
i believe i am familiar
enough with this stuff and i see
patterns and indicators of success
and i see a correlation um
you know and i and i believe it and not
only in me
every experienced right every like 100
percent of the not 100
maybe 95 98 of experienced writers that
i know
absolutely feel like again it's not
binary they can't read a line or a page
and go this is definitively crap or
definitely good
but you know you know
all my peers i absolutely would put
money on them
looking at a particular random script
and after reading one page
they all for sure could say this is an
amateur level writer or this is a
you know probably not even 100 but i
think for the most part
and it's just because there's what i
think the people they get upset about
is they don't they don't know what they
don't know they don't realize
how many choices
they're making on the page and that's
probably why they get pissed off is
because
they're going okay the character gets in
the car or and such and such happens but
right
but like you know i've written 25 30
screenplays so i've
and and that's just like finished ones
not to mention some of those drafts were
15 20 30 drafts and probably another 30
treatment so like
i've been in the game for a while i've
seen a lot of stuff and
and you just get familiar with the same
thing over and over and over again so
um so what they so a
person writing their first second third
screenplay for them
they're just focusing on basic oh
there's a guy i see him in the car and
they just say guy gets in the car
but like you know i'm seeing that same
line and i'm thinking of on 10 levels
you know i'm thinking of it on
how many words the how muscular the
words are the
cadence what's going on before that and
after um
you know how um you know
symbolically how does it relate to the
theme you know and again i don't do all
that on the first draft but by the time
i get to that end draft
every line i've thought about dozens and
dozens of times with those different
lenses
and because i have that much familiarity
with every single line in my screenplay
um i can read a line from an amateur
who's
probably looked at that line two times
three times five times
um and when i look at something two
times five times it's like that it's not
really
it does you know it looks like a rough
rock it doesn't look like a gem when
i've seen something a dozen times 20
times especially after all my experience
it shines in a different way you just
the magic comes through it in a way
that's different
so um even if you were to look at you
know my first draft and my last draft
you're just seeing a rougher edge with
all those things and that's just part of
the process
that's another thing is that a lot of um
amateur writers they won't do as many
drafts
as they need to to really shine or
they'll do the drafts but
they're changing the wrong damn things
that don't even make a difference
which kind of breaks my heart because
they've got enough creativity and they
love it enough but they don't
know the way through the forest so they
end up spending
years and years wandering around and
then some of them quit
it's terrible can you give me an example
of of
poorly used cadence um
so poorly used that's an interesting
question poorly used cadence
in dialogue would be something that
doesn't sound authentic to that
character
right usually it's the writer's own
voice they all sound like you know me
and you know what the truth is
um i am fine writing my early drafts
pretty much with everybody in my in my
in my voice i mean why not i mean if i
have an ear for them fine i'll do it but
like
even if the thing i'm writing now has
this british character
and you know i'm doing kind of a you
know whatever loose idea of a british
i'll imagine like a guy from hell's
kitchen or like pierce morgan
what did he say but like i don't sweat
it it's sort of like it's more like me
kind of doing a bad british accent or
whatever you know that's kind of the
cadence that i'm hearing
and then as i get to draft drafts i'll
maybe bring in a friend who's british
and go dude can you take a look at this
and he'll go yeah we would never say
this we would never do that
you know or like when i was writing
astronauts it was great to um
get real astronauts and go um yeah we
described this stuff and we're kind of
like pulling it off stuff we got on the
internet i don't you know you tell me
and it was really exciting every time
they're like no no that's legit that's
right i was like
wow it is it's amazing so um
cadence for a line of description
really where your voice comes from as a
screenwriter
um you know hemingway very classically
had this
very simple sort of style
um there's most of the screenwriters on
the that make the blacklist every year
have a pretty visceral sense of their
voice so if you look at
you pick three scripts from the
blacklist and you look at their first
couple lines
on their first page you're going to
probably see slight differences in
cadence
in the way they they talk and it's just
you feel it
it's weird because it's it's cadence is
different
it's a rhythmic thing um uh and you know
word choice plays part of it but it's
just sort of a
it's a rhythm i think the first time i
thought about i learned about that sort
of thing was um
spike lee um one of his books
you know his first you know how i made
this how i made she's got to have it
whatever that book was
but it was um i read the book and i was
like oh this is exactly the way spike
talks and like interviews and stuff
and i was like oh you can do that you're
not supposed to write this kind of fakey
fake format that you learn in school
and it was like and it was so it just
felt more personal
you know so i think um screenwriters
that have a great voice
they describe those action scenes with
um not so much like so strongly there
but like there's a sense of
their cadence in this genre in service
to this particular story so i haven't
read a
spike screenplay in a while so i don't
know exactly what he does on the page
but i would imagine
it's i mean the thing i read of his was
non-fiction so it was very much his
voice
but voices is great it's probably one of
the things that um
again most of the scripts that make the
blacklist every year are
are mostly powerful in in voice
um and then somewhat in concept although
some of the concepts are not very strong
um and then they can execute but i in my
ucla extension class we would often
teach a lot of those screenplays from
the blacklist
and very interestingly the um the
ratings were all over the board
it wasn't like you know i wouldn't tell
them which ones were sometimes i would
sometimes i wouldn't
but like it didn't matter there was
literally um
some of the scripts they hated the most
in class blacklist scripts
wow it's it's there's so much
subjectivity in the business so you just
have to
know how to getting back to that
feedback system
you know how to take subjectivity out of
it you need enough data points
so that it's not um one person is never
making or breaking you or one contest or
one whatever
you need enough data points so that um
uh subjectivity is not a significant
factor
i think kevin smith too has a very
distinct cadence for his writing and
in his book and um that's right when you
talk about muscular words
yeah can you give me an example of a
weak muscular word
versus a strong one um
so um muscular is sort of like the
opposite of
um pat you know passive to a passive
active is more different but you can say
passive or active and active even more
muscular so
um we are talking right
it's a passive way in a very bland way
um
um we are enthralled in conversation
and maybe that's even a little too
flowery but right but we are um
digging into the meat of the craft of
screenwriting
you know you can feel the difference
between those different word choices
and the amateur will do things like we
are talking
and and that's why you can see it in one
one one sentence
and then you might have somebody who's
getting again you know
the other thing i said about enthralled
or whatever that might be a little bit
too flowery right
um but you'll see the um
the writers that have that voice there's
there's a poetry to it it's just
beautiful
it's just enough sort of
flourish on it's not too fancy or
sometimes it will be uh there was a guy
that wrote um
uh freda's name but he um anyway any
great screenwriter
has really distinct cadence and voice
you